[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à j arrête le sport c'est beaucoup trop
fatigante l'audi quelque chose ça vous
êtes peut-être dans le même cas que moi
vous êtes dit à plus ou moins plus ou
moins récemment que vous n'aviez pas le
temps pas l'envié ou tout simplement
vous préfériez faire autre chose bien
allongé au fond de votre canapé
mais je suis sûr vous êtes aussi
rattrapé par ce petit sentiment de
culpabilité
vous savez c'est celui qui vous fait
dire faudrait que je me bouge un peu ça
me ferait du bien
ou alors qu'il faudrait peut-être
éliminé l'andouille de charlieu et la
praline hier soir bon ce petit sentiment
de culpabilité vous l'avez lorsque vous
savez au fond de vous-même que la
pratique sportive c'est bon pour la
santé
et vous avez raison puisque de
nombreuses études scientifiques ont
montré tout d'abord que la pratique
sportive permettrait d'améliorer la
santé physique notamment en améliorant
les grandes fonctions physiologiques et
en permettant également faire en aidant
à éviter l'apparition de certaines
maladies
la pratique sportive allait aussi bonne
pour la santé mentale
elle permettrait d'améliorer le
bien-être et les cimes de soi et en fait
permettrait d'améliorer la santé social
en améliorant les relations avec les
autres et en permettant une meilleure
insertion sociale alors bien sûr ses
messages de prévention voulait rabat je
vous ai l'habitude de les entendre ou
cesse et les messages qu'on voit en bas
des pubs ou qu'on entend la radio pour
votre santé pratiquez une activité
physique régulière pour votre santé
manger au moins cinq fruits et légumes
par jour pour votre sainteté ne mangez
pas trop gras trop sucré trop salé pour
votre santé
oh c'est bon là non bon ces messages de
prévention il se décline à de nombreuses
échelle de l'échelle la plus globale
par exemple avec l'organisation mondiale
de la santé les messages qu'elle délivre
et à l'échelle la plus locale la plus
proche de vous c'est le dimanche quand
vous allez à votre repas de famille et
que votre grande tonnes geneviève elle
vous fait remarquer vous est pris d joue
un peu là bref si on revient qu'on est
un peu plus sérieux donc ses messages de
prévention
il y en a tellement qu'on sait plus trop
ce qui est vraiment bon pour la santé
par exemple les 10
par jour vous avez certainement entendu
ça ou alors les 60 minutes d'activité
modérée a soutenu par jour alors bien
sûr il faut aussi relativiser les effets
de la pratique sportive notamment le
premier exemple ce sont les blessures
alors chez les 15 25 ans près d'un
accident sur deux de la vie quotidienne
est due aux blessures
si je prends un deuxième exemple qui
concerne plutôt la santé mentale et
sociale
eh bien je suis sûr que le regard des
autres vous savez que ça peu difficile
notamment quand on fait de la pratique
sportive le regard des autres qui peut
être particulièrement difficile et je
suis sûr qu'il ya certains d'entre vous
qui reste encore aujourd'hui un peu
traumatisés par leur prof de ps jean
philippe qui de ps2 gym ou de sport ça
dépend de l'époque à laquelle on a on a
été à l'école bref en tout cas c'est
tous ces messages de prévention m
ils sont importants et malgré toutes les
campagnes de promotion de la pratique
sportive en france et dans d'autres pays
occidentaux on assiste à une stagnation
voire à une baisse de la pratique
sportive et la population qui la plus
concernée par cette baisse sont les
adolescents alors si on prend une étude
qui a été menée dans les bouches du
rhône par mon équipe de recherche donc
le graff qui derrière moi il représente
l'évolution des taux de pratique
sportive de jeunes scolarisés entre 2001
et 2015 et donc mon équipe de recherche
a montré que si en 2001 il y avait 79 %
de jeunes qui pratiquent une activité
sportive régulièrement c'est-à-dire au
moins une fois par semaine au moins une
heure par semaine ils n'étaient plus que
72 % en 2008 et enfin n'étaient plus que
66 % plus récemment en 2015 alors pour
quelle raison est ce que il est
important de ceux de s'intéresser
particulièrement aux jeunes
donc il ya trois raisons la première
c'est parce qu'il y aurait un pic de
pratiquer jusqu'à l'âge de 12 ans c'est
à dire que dans une génération jusqu'à
l'âge de 12 ans il y aurait de plus en
plus de pratiquants sportifs et autour
de l'âge de 12 ans il commencerait à y
avoir une baisse la deuxième raison
c'est que l'activité sportive est une
activité qui est privilégié notamment
par les jeunes pour être physiquement
actif et enfin la troisième raison c'est
que la pratique sportive à l'adolescence
serait prédictive de la pratique
sportive à l'âge adulte
c'est à dire que l'adoption de
comportements de santé et d'habitudes de
santé dans l'enfance et dalo et
d'adolescents et à l'adolescence se
perpétuerait ensuite à l'âge adulte
bon vous avez bien dû comprendre que ce
qui m'intéresse c'est d'essayer de
comprendre d'un point de vue
sociologique
pourquoi les ados sont de grosses
feignasses
pourquoi les ados abandonne la pratique
sportive
c'est ça alors je vous ai tous votre
avis allez on va prendre qu'est ce qu'on
va prendre par exemple vous monsieur
vous allez me dire qu'avec leur
smartphone et leur playstation dont sans
cesse le nez collé aux écrans non oui
mais c'est un peu court jeune homme
bon pour mieux comprendre je suis parti
à leur rencontre et je les ai
questionnés sur les raisons qui les ont
poussé à abandonner le sport et suite à
une centaine d'entretiens que j'ai
réalisé cinq thèmes des influences se
sont dégagées mais laissons la parole
aux principaux intéressés
ils ont dit aux dieux il ya des choses
en somme on va rien le ton par exemple
donné agressif moi monsieur si j'en suis
venu à arrêter sa cause études j'ai
donné priorité amical tous mes amis
adoré ce sont des filets me trouvant
esseulé je dû abandonner descriptif ses
rues de cet art du c'est dur que dis je
c'est dur c'est une torture
curieux à quoi peut servir la sportive
activités hormis de prendre le risque de
se blesser gracieux ma famille et moi
même avons déménagé le club fut éloigné
pour encore pratiquée voilà ce qu'à peu
près michel m'avait dit
car les ados sont pétris de lait trait
d'esprit bon je suis peut-être allé un
peu vite en merci peut-être allé un peu
vite en besogne
je vais reprendre un peu plus calmement
surtout que cela se fait déjà trois
heures donc donc voilà comment ces prix
méthodologiquement tout d'abord on a
constitué ce qu'on appelle des guides
d'entretien une fois qu'on a fait c'est
guy d'entretien messieurs nous a fallu
trouver des jeunes d'âge de sexe et de
catégories socioprofessionnelles
différentes et pour ça rien de mieux que
d'aller donc dans les collèges et les
lycées dans les collèges et les lycées
nous avons réalisé une centaine
d'entretiens que nous avons ensuite
retranscrits sous forme de ce qu'on
appelle des verbatim qui permettent
ensuite d'analyser et d'interpréter les
résultats et donc on a obtenu un grand
nombre de raisons qui étaient évoquées
pour expliquer l'abandon de la pratique
sportive et ces raisons on les a
regroupés sous cinq thèmes et ses thèmes
on les a interprétés comme étant des
domaines de la vie sociale ou ce que
georg simmel appelle des cercles de la
vie sociale c'est à dire que chaque
individu vous tous ici vous accorder du
temps et de l'importance à différents
éléments dans votre vie qu'on pourrait
représenter comme des temps des cercles
par exemple votre cercle familial votre
cercle amical
le sarc de votre travail une série de
vos loisirs etc et donc lorsqu'un
individu abandonne la pratique sportive
il abandonne le cercle de la pratique
sportive et en plus cet abandon et les
lier aux différents cercles différents
éléments dans sa vie alors donc nous
dans notre étude on en a identifié cinq
que je vais reprendre avec vous le
premier c'était lié à des au cercle de
la famille un déménagement ou alors un
contrôle familial pointent une punition
qui étaient infligés infligée
aux enfants pour qu'ils arrêtent la
pratique sportive
le deuxième cercle qui était davantage
lié à des raisons liées aux amitiés
alors c'était soit des amitiés soyez
liés à la pratique sportive par exemple
mes amis ont abandonné donc j'ai terminé
j'ai fini par abandonner soient liés à
des amitiés en dehors de la pratique un
attrait pour des amitiés
je préfère sortir avec mes copains
plutôt que de faire du sport par exemple
le troisième cercle c'était celui du
corps alors là c'était surtout lié bien
sûr à la blessure ou à la peur de se
reblesser le quatrième thème est pas des
moines c'était le cercle scolaire et là
il ya une notion qui est assez
importante
c est qui m'a sait plus qui est cher à
péret nous c'est le métier d'élève
c'est à dire que le fait d'être élève
constituer un réel métier dans la mesure
où on a des contraintes de déplacement
des contraintes d'horaires des
contraintes de travail et des
contraintes de réussite et toutes ces
raisons elle pouvait être invoquée pour
expliquer un abandon est en fait le
dernier cercle c'est le cercle de la
pratique sportive lui même c'est à dire
que le sport peut être à l'origine de
son propre abandon et là on avait quatre
sous-thèmes le premier c'était des
raisons liées à l'accessibilité ya pas
de club où on n'a pas assez d'argent
le deuxième c'était lié à la réussite
dans la pratique sportive
je ne sens pas assez compétent je me
sens pas assez progressé où j'ai eu je
gagne pas assez le troisième c'était des
raisons qui étaient liés aux
caractéristiques propres à la pratique
sportive
c'est répétitif c'est fatigant par
exemple et enfin le dernier s'était lié
aux relations avec les autres dans la
pratique sportive notamment les
relations avec le coach le coach me
plaît pas ou il plaisait mais après la
notre relation s'est dégradée où
l'ambiance globalement de pratiques qui
étaient très régulièrement invoqué alors
ces raisons les jeunes ils pouvaient les
exprimer de manière isolée
une seule raison je me suis blessé j'ai
arrêté par exemple mais bien souvent le
processus ils étaient bien plus complexe
et dans ce cas là on a identifié deux
processus
soit il s'agissait de ce qu'on a appelé
un effet de cascade et dans ce cas là il
y avait une raison qui en enchaîner une
autre qui s'enchaînaient qui terminait
par l'abandon exemple une année fait
l'année où j'ai arrêté quand j'ai
commencé quand j'ai commencé le sport on
avait changé de coach est en fait mes
copines elle l'aimé pas trop donc y en a
une qui a abandonné puis une autre puis
une autre et enfin car j'ai pu de
copines pour pratiquer j'ai arrêté aussi
ça c'est plutôt l'effet de cascades et
l'autre processus c'est plutôt un effet
boule de neige alors l'effet boule de
neige c'est pas de l'enchaînement c'est
plutôt de l'accumulation c'est à dire si
on prend un exemple ça pouvait être et
bien quand je suis rentré en troisième
j'ai commencé à avoir de plus en plus de
devoir et en plus au début la troisième
je me suis un peu fait mal à la cheville
mais mes parents m'ont dit bof tu as du
travail thèmes peuvent à la cheville qui
reprendra l'année prochaine et
finalement le jeune ne reprend jamais
alors ses raisons bien sûr ça peut être
soit des contraintes qui se dresse entre
le pratiquant et sa pratique
ou alors ça peut être plutôt un
processus décisionnel dans ce cas là
c'est un choix plus ou moins éclairés
bien sûr celui d'arrêter
et enfin pour terminer je vais faire un
petit jeu avec vous c'est à dire qu'on a
essayé on now également regarder en
fonction du moment où les jeunes donc en
fonction de l'âge de l'arrêt on a essayé
de voir s'il y avait certains cercles
qui était plus régulièrement évoquée que
d'autres alors votre avis si on prend à
l'école primaire
quand ils ont arrêté avant dix ans
c'était plutôt quel cercle qui était qui
étaient évoquées restaient plutôt le
cercle de la famille
maintenant que j'ai l'éclairage vais
pouvoir que vous questionnez vous
travaillé un peu lorsque l'arrêt avait
plutôt lieu au collège à votre avis
étaient plutôt quel cercle qui était qui
est évoqué alors c'était plutôt alors
pas forcément la famille mais c'était
plutôt le cercle de la pratique sportive
elle même et enfin au lycée
à votre avis étaient plutôt plus tôt
l'école on est d'accord c'est
effectivement l'école le métier d'élève
la pression scolaire qui pouvaient qui
était le plus régulièrement évoqué alors
c'est c3 c3 moment de l'arrêt c'est
important parce que et ses résultats ils
sont importants parce qu'ils permettent
de mieux
berné les messages de prévention c'est à
dire que pour les plus jeunes mais on va
plutôt chercher à cibler les familles
pour les collégiens qui sont dans la
fleur de l'adolescence on va plutôt
essayer de voir avec les éducateurs
sportifs et les entraîneurs et pour les
plus grands il faudrait peut-être avoir
une réflexion poussée avec le milieu
éducatif
j'ai essayé de vous présenter la un
cadre de compression celui qu'ont
adressé celui de l'abandon la pratique
sportive
ce cas de compréhension on pourrait
également à l'appliquer à l'abandon
d'autres loisirs comme la musique ou
d'autres loisirs mais ils permettent on
pourrait également l'utiliser pour
essayer de comprendre la reprise de la
pratique sportive
c'est à dire comment est ce que certains
individus qui ont abandonné je suis sûr
qu'il y en a plein ici dans la salle qui
ont fait ça aussi qu abandonner à un
moment mais qui à un moment où aussi
réintégrer ce cercle au sein de leur vie
et ses résultats ils sont importants et
ce qui est important c'est d'être à
l'écouté je pense des jeunes ce que je
les ai taquiner un aujourd'hui et je
vous assure je les aime bien et surtout
je vais je vous assure
et je suis persuadé qu'on est passé à
leur écoute alors qu'ils ont plein
choses intéressantes à dire si on les
écoute sur l'ours qu'ils expliquent les
raisons pour lesquelles ils abandonnent
et ce qu'ils ont envie de pratiquer la
manière dont ils ont envie de la
pratique et c'est là qu'on pourra leur
proposer des pratiques sportives et des
manières les pratiques et au plus proche
de leurs aspirations et là sur la
reprise la pratique sportive il ya
d'espoir parce que près d'un jeune sur
deux dans mes entretiens disait qu'il
souhaitait reprendre la pratique
sportive mais qu'il ne pouvait qui
n'était pas dans les conditions de le
faire voilà donc j'espère que ce petit
moment passé ensemble vous a plu
j'espère vous n'êtes pas trop
culpabiliser 2
d'être ravagée depuis près de quatre
heures dans votre fauteuil c'était pas
le but
bon et où gérard gérard et où la praline
là parce qu'à la fin de l'envoi mois
faut que je bouffe
[Applaudissements]